THE STATE OF COMPUTERS:
Have you noticed that nobody uses
computers anymore? Ok alright, before you get mad
and leave a nasty comment, obviously, computers
are still extremely popular. Literally over a
billion people still own computers and hundreds
of millions use them everyday for work, school,
and entertainment. Personally, I’m very much part
of this group as I’m running two computers as we
speak just to record this, but that’s not what I’m
talking about. I’m talking about a larger macro
shift away from computers. Take internet traffic
stats for example. Every month, Google gets 35.5
billion visits, but 77% of those visits or 27.5
billion visits are from mobile. And this trend
holds across the board. In fact, several websites
skew even more towards smartphones. YouTube is
85% smartphones, Reddit is 81%, DuckDuckGo is 90%,
Wikipedia is 80%, and certain other sites, well
they’re around 95%. Looking through the list,
you’d be pretty hard pressed to find websites
that are actually majority desktop. And usually
those are older websites that are largely
used by older people. For example, Yahoo
is only 43% mobile and Microsoft Online is only
21% mobile. But putting aside those exceptions,
it’s clear that the skew is overwhelmingly towards
smartphones, which if you think about it makes
sense. Nowadays, people do everything from their
smartphones whether it’s investing, buying a car,
buying a house, reading the news, you name it.
Really, the only time that most people still use
computers is for productivity. You know, if your
job or school requires Microsoft Office or coding
or 3d modeling or bunch of virtual meetings, you
get the idea. But putting aside productivity,
people tend to do everything on their smartphones.
But why? Obviously, phones are more convenient
on the go, but when you’re not on the go,
computers can accomplish a lot more. Yet,
the stats suggest that unless people have to use
their computers, they don’t. So why in the world
does nobody use computers anymore, and what does
this mean for the future of desktop vs mobile?
THE QUANTITATIVE EXPLANATION:
Obviously this hasn’t always been the
case as smartphones haven’t even been around for
2 decades at this point, but with that being said,
that also means that it hasn’t taken long for
this trend to take hold, so what happened? Well,
I think this trend can largely be explained by 3
overarching factors starting with demographics.
You see, this trend has less to do with computer
users suddenly using their smartphones more and
more to do with younger people just never using
computers. I mean, just look at the stats. The
average person spends 3 hours and 15 minutes
everyday on their smartphones which is already
a lot of time. Millennials aren’t too much worse
coming in slightly higher at 3.7 hours per day.
But, do you wanna guess how much time Gen Z
spends on their smartphones everyday? Maybe 4,
5, 6 hours? Well, it’s actually up to 9 hours.
A lot of these people have rigorous full time
jobs and they still have insane amounts of
screentime. Basically, if they’re not actively
working on something that requires a computer
or sleeping, they’re on their phones. Now,
you could go down the whole rabbit whole of how
healthy is this but that’s outside the scope of
this video. What we’re really concerned about is
how this affects smartphone usage, and clearly,
it affects it enormously. The average person only
uses their computer for 2 hours and 51 minutes per
day. So when a single zoomer clocks in over 3
times that on just their phones, it’s no wonder
why the stats are skewed towards smartphones.
But that’s just the first reason, which brings
us into the vastly different context of mobile
and desktop usage. When you use computers,
you naturally tend to be working on something
more intense that requires singular focus. So,
even though you might end up spending hours on
a computer in any given session, it’s likely
that you only visited a handful of websites
and programs. If you’re a coder for example,
even if you spent 10 hours in front of the screen,
it’s likely that your entire screen time only
consisted of Slack, Visual Studio, Zoom, Stack
Overflow, and Gmail. In contrast, if you spent
10 hours in front of a smartphone, it’s likely
that your screen time was far more diverse. Sure,
you might’ve only visited offerings from Google,
Meta, and Amazon, but the number of individual
pages you visited would likely be in the hundreds
if not over a 1000. If you’re scrolling through
TikTok for example, you’re essentially visiting
a new page every 5 seconds when you swipe. Even
if you’re just surfing the web, you’re much more
likely to bounce around. In fact, the average time
spent on a desktop site is 40% longer than the
average time spent on a mobile site. So, again
considering that, it’s no surprise why internet
traffic heavily leans in the favor of mobile.
But all of that really only applies to western
countries which brings us into the 3rd reason:
the developing world. It’s only in western
countries where almost everyone has access
to both a smartphone and a computer and it’s up
to their mood as to what they use. When we look
at the developing world though, people can often
only afford one or the other, and when put in that
situation, they overwhelmingly choose to go with a
smartphone. In terms of numbers, there are roughly
1.4 billion Windows PCs worldwide. If you throw
in Mac and Linux onto that, maybe that number
goes up to 1.7 or 1.8 billion. But, do you wanna
guess how many smartphones are out there? The
answer is 6.94 billion or 85% of the entire world
population. Yeah, I don’t think that requires any
additional explanation. So essentially, internet
traffic is dominated by smartphones due Gen Z,
smartphone users bouncing around more often,
and the developing world at large. But,
all of that only tells the quantitative side of
the story which still leaves the question of why.
THE QUALITATIVE EXPLANATION:
Here’s the thing, given the data we’ve discussed,
it’s obvious that Gen Z and the developing
world are skewing the data towards smartphones,
but there’s more to this story because I don’t
think that that’s a forced reality. Virtually
every Zoomer has access to both a smartphone and
a computer, so the fact that they spend 9 hours
a day on smartphones is very much a choice. Also,
regarding the developing world, even if you gave
them all computers right now, I suspect that their
use would still primarily skew towards smartphones
for which I’ve got an explanation which primarily
centers on the vastly different adoptions curves
of the computer and the smartphone. The
traditional computer can be traced all the
way back to 1822, but the average person didn’t
get a personal computer till the 1990s and really
the 2000s. You could say that this was because
computers were simply too expensive before the
90s but you could say the same things about a car.
Cars are super expensive but the average person
has been getting cars since the Model T days
because the need outweighs the high price. For
computers, however, that was simply not the case
because computers were not initially designed for
average people. It was designed for corporations,
governments, and universities to conduct research,
do mathematical analyses, and create communication
and storage infrastructure. The average person in
the 70s and 80s had no use for any of that, so
buying a computer for personal use was more of
a novelty than anything. The fact that computers
eventually became applicable to the average person
was more of a byproduct of innovation as opposed
to the focus of innovation. With smartphones,
however, it was the exact opposite. At most, you
can say that the first smartphone was created
in 1992 but smartphones really had no utility in
society for businesses or people until the iPhone.
And as for the iPhone, well, that was designed
specifically for the consumer. Everything from the
over the top animations and intuitive gestures to
the seemingly infinite app store and inviting UI,
it was all designed as a luxury purchase for
the average person. And this difference has
set the stage for everything that came about
on both platforms. And you don’t even have to
look that far to spot these differences. Take
Google for instance, something that came out
during the computer era. Originally, Google was
a Stanford research project meant to help people
research. It just so happened that everyday people
eventually found utility in consulting Google on
a regular basis. Now, in contrast, take a look at
mobile first services like Uber, AirBnB, SnapChat,
Instagram, TikTok, Robinhood, DoorDash, and so on.
Each and every one of these services were designed
from the ground up to maximize on consumption from
all fronts whether that’s screen time, engagement,
revenue, market share, you name it. So, from
that perspective, it’s really not surprising
why people prefer to spend a lot more time on a
device that was created for consumption as opposed
to a device that was created for utility. And this
association has been engraved in people’s minds.
That’s probably why you tend to use your laptop
at your desk but your phone or your tablet on your
bed or couch. The bottomline is that people use
computers because it’s a utility that they need
while they use smartphones because it’s a luxury
that they want. Now of course, you can argue that
in the modern age, smartphones are very much also
a need and I completely agree with that. But,
I would also argue that want still plays a far
larger role with smartphones than it does with
computers. That’s why people are far more likely
to purchase a flagship smartphone as opposed to
a flagship computer, even if prices were the
same. So, that kind of explains why nobody
uses computers anymore both from a quantitative
standpoint and a qualitative standpoint. And
that leaves just one question: what does this mean
for the future of the desktop and mobile markets?
DESKTOP VS MOBILE:
Corporations are well aware of this trend and
that’s why they’ve shifted their entire focus
towards smartphones. This includes building
better mobile websites, better mobile apps,
and of course, spending a lot more on mobile ads.
I mean just take a look at this chart. In 2013,
desktop ad spend stood at $32 billion while
mobile ad spend stood at just $10 billion or a
third of desktop ad spend. By 2015 though, they
were both at roughly $30 billion and by 2019,
mobile had grown to $65 billion while desktop was
down to $25 billion. And as you would probably
guess, this disparity has only grown evern
further thanks to the pandemic. As of 2023,
mobile accounts for 70% of programmatic digital
ad spend within the US while desktops and laptops
only account for a mere 13%. Does this mean that
computers are just dead and companies will stop
offering desktop platforms? No, of course not.
While people prefer to spend the majority of their
time on mobile devices, they still very much value
having a desktop option as well. For example, with
banking, I probably only log on to the desktop
portal a few times a year while I log in to the
mobile portal almost every day. But, I still very
much value the desktop portal because it makes
downloading account statements and filing taxes a
lot easier. Similarly, if I’ve watching Netflix,
it’s always on my iPad or TV, but if I were to
manage my membership or cancel my subscription,
I’d probably do it on the computer. And I get
the feeling that this is how most people feel,
let me know down below if you agree. With that
being said, I suspect that services will become
more and more mobile centered while desktop
offerings become more and more geared towards
managing these services or doing tasks that
aren’t as easy on mobile. Desktops will also of
course continue to be extremely relevant when
it comes to productivity, but that’s why the
internet is now dominated by smartphones. Another
industry that has seen an extremely interesting
evolution is TVs which seem to infinitely get
cheaper. Check out this video to learn more.